so that's where you and i have a very
deep kind of agreement um
uh because i i consider myself a
neoplatonist
in my sort of ultimate orientation
i guess what i would say
and plato i think might agree with me is
he would say well saying it doesn't
exist physically it doesn't say much
because the physics is ultimately less
real
than uh the platonic objects of which uh
right because the physical things the
instantiated things are only as you said
only temporary instances right they're
less stable they're less real and so the
fact that it doesn't exist physically
doesn't sound
like to plato's ears they would go yeah
and that's that's to say that they're
more real um than a physical reality in
an important way um and that seems to me
um
kind of what you need in order to do
science uh you need to be able to posit
these kinds of entities in order to do
generalizations
in in order to
be audacious in some ways the
empiricists wouldn't like the fact that
i could run some math and make
conclusions about reality i mean you you
have to believe
like stronger you have to assert this
kind of thing um and now i
um you seem to be nodding so i don't
think i'm being too imposing on you and
i'm finding that we got to this place
very very interesting because and i want
and i don't mean this as any kind of
critique of your presentation
i didn't get that when i was watching
your videos right it took it took it
took a lot of this no and again i'm not
critiquing you but i i found that i've
now gotten to a very very interesting
place with you um i i don't know what uh
we haven't said too much about
consciousness and meaning like we
promised we would but i found this uh
this progression really really powerful
and interesting um
because i'm also interested
you have a knack for saying very
intriguing things about religion and
history um i'm very interested
in the fact that platonism neoplatonism
because they were continuity uh formed
an interesting kind of lingua
intellectual lingua franca along the
silk road
you can even see this historically
neoplatonism was able to reciprocally
reconstruct with christianity uh with
islam uh with judaism and there's
there's now some evidence even with
buddhism it seems to have this
interesting capacity to be
more of a ur or primordial
representation of our shared
intelligibility making processes i find
that a very interesting proposal
right now um because if we could get the
philosophical argument we've been
exploring and the historical argument
together
that means
we could make a plausible argument for a
shareable
framework for interpreting uh reality
and making and making claims about
reality and normative judgments and i
think this is very centrally needed
for a problem i talk about extensively
which is the meaning crisis uh that the
west is facing so i just wanted to say i
i mean i've been sort of like
very critical but i want to now stand
back and express appreciation uh for
sort of where we got to and some of the
possibilities i see in it now i hope
that also wasn't uh imposing on you but
you were nodding as i was saying it so
it seemed like it was
outlandish but you don't need to
apologize in this way in any way i don't
identify with me having these ideas i
can observe myself having ideas but the
relationship that the ideas have to me
is not very interesting i just try to
play the glass punch wheel as well as i
can as you do as do you right so you
never need to apologize for criticizing
an idea or having a different one or
pointing out where my thinking falls
short i'm i'm grateful if you point out
things that appear to be inconsistent so
don't worry about this at all
fair enough you're playing you're
playing you're playing the music with me
very well and i appreciate that my point
for making the apology first of all i'm
a canadian we apologize for everything
secondly uh the point for me was to
trying to show you from where i was
coming that i wasn't that was the point
i was trying i was trying to make um
so i'm i'm interested
can i ask you a question
it's slightly more personal um
i think it's fair to say that the
position you've taken
because i've i've interacted with a lot
of cognitive scientists uh who are
computer scientists the position you've
taken isn't
like
isn't the consensus position or even the
majority position
is that fair to say
yes and no i find that uh a lot of
people who deeply think about these
topics seem to be converging so if i
would be discussing with say people like
uh
minsky dasher
um many many other people uh next uh
thursday uh will have a discussion about
attention with uh michael graciano and
uh
vasudev and jonathan cohen who come from
ai and neuroscience and uh
cognitive science or philosophy uh and
we've been discussing attention and its
relationship to consciousness ultimately
yeah and i find that there is a large
convergence in these ideas i also don't
find that my ideas are in a deep sense
original it's just that uh the more
ideas i discover the smaller the parties
become that i am late to
uh
you know what i mean right so i i don't
think that's possible to have
philosophical ideas about the
relationship between mind and physical
universe that have not been had by
somebody a few thousand years ago and if
somebody has a fundamentally new idea
that's probably bad news
unless it relates to some kind of super
modern physics in a highly original way
and
it's possible that we find discover
something on this level but by and large
um
the big foundational questions about
epistemology and so on are apparent for
so long that i don't have any claims to
originality in there
and
so
i would say that my ideas are not
original and are also relatively
widespread
and the disagreements are largely uh
happening i think at the uh
when people have different epistemology
when they think that there are ways to
establishing truths that are different
from the ways in which i think that
truth can be established sure sure i
think that's why i wanted to play at the
epistemological ontological level with
you i'm interested though that because i
also have a sense
of
of a growing convergence um
and
that's why i liked the fact that you do
a big picture card in science because i
think you have to do big picture
cognitive science to get that sense to
to really get it um
and and
i i'm wondering um
in your practice of doing cognitive
science
how do you deal
because i agree with you about that
convergence and i agree with you
how do you deal with
the um
the different ontologies right so the
neuroscientist talks about neurons and
does fmri
and
the artificial intelligence person talks
about programs and runs simulations and
hoping that they become instantiations
the psychologist talks about working
memory
and does you know experiments on
behavior the linguist talks about deep
structures
and right collects data about judgments
of grammaticality
how do you
this question really concerns me because
i think it it's part of
again
trying to turn cognitive science back
towards the existential issue that's
facing us i don't mean existential a
sense of threat i mean like how
kirkegaard would use the word
existential with the meaning-making i go
back to the point i made
at the very beginning
right
that for a long time
the cognitive sciences and i'll use that
plural as opposed to cognitive science
that tries to do a synoptic integration
the cognitive scientists the cognitive
sciences have promoted a fragmentation
of what mind means in a profound way
and that fragmentation
has right really when people start to
reflect and
they can off i see this in my students
right they'll get caught up on i don't
know what this i don't know what a mind
is because there's this there's this
cacophony of all and and then of course
if i don't know what a mind is i don't
know what i am and i don't know how i
relate to the world you can see where
this goes the fragmentation of the
ontology
by the cognitive scientists
is not separate from a lot of
the the the the suffering that people
have because they don't find a stable
framework in which to locate the
phenomena of mind so
i'm asking this because as i said i
and you invoked wisdom a while back and
so i wanted to circle back to that um
what wisdom have you
acquired
cultivated realized i don't know what
verb you want
for helping
do this
get
two things getting the various
disciplines to start to pursue
integration
rather than fragmentation
and connecting that to
sort of the general issue of how we as
embodied minded beings fit into a
scientific worldview i know that's a big
question but i i'm really interested in
it